júbilo y alivio en la Unión Europea tras
la victoria de Luis Ignacio Lula da
Silva en las elecciones de Brasil los
tres presidentes de las instituciones
europeas ya han felicitado al recién
elegido presidente y los tres han
mostrado su confianza y esperanza en
poder seguir trabajando con el nuevo
presidente de Brasil sobre todo se ha
hecho hincapié en los desafíos en la
guerra en Ucrania pero también en el
cambio climático una de las cuestiones
principales en las que quiere abordar la
Unión Europea con Brasil la regresión
que ha supuesto en materia climática las
políticas de Yair bolsonaro provocaron
varias fricciones entre la Unión Europea
y Brasil ahora se espera que haya un
punto y aparte de hecho es una de las
cuestiones en la lucha contra el cambio
climático que hizo que el acuerdo de que
mantiene la Unión Europea con los países
de mercosur este bloqueado a pesar de
que se pudo aprobar hace tres años ahora
mismo Está congelado entre otras
cuestiones porque el parla europeo voto
que el acuerdo tal y como está ahora
mismo era imposible de ratificar
justamente por estas dudas en materia
climática y por las políticas
medioambientales de Yair bolsonaro pero
también por las dudas de países como
Francia o Austria que no veían con
buenos ojos este acuerdo tampoco en
materia agrícola ahora creen que con los
enlaces de Luna da Silva las cosas
pueden cambiar mucho de hecho la
comisión europea está dispuesta a
proponer cambios de aquí a finales de
año para que el acuerdo pueda ser
favorable para las dos partes aún así se
cree que a pesar de que se puede cambiar
el acuerdo puede tardar años hasta que
pueda ratificarse